Welcome back to Understanding Quantum Information and Computation.
My name is John Watchras, and I'm the Technical Director for Education at IBM Quantum.
This is the eighth lesson of the series, and it's the last lesson in the second unit of the series, which is on quantum algorithms.
We've talked about the query model of computation, including quantum algorithms that offer provable advantages over classical algorithms within that model.
We've discussed foundational concepts connected with quantum algorithms and how we can measure computational cost, and in the previous lesson we discussed phase estimation and Shor's algorithm.
In this lesson, we'll discuss Grover's algorithm, which provides a quadratic advantage of quantum over classical algorithms for so-called unstructured search problems, which I'll describe once we get into the lesson.
These are all foundational topics concerning quantum algorithms.
There are other quantum algorithms, as well as general paradigms that unite different quantum algorithms and quantum algorithmic techniques, and if you're interested, I encourage you to check out the Quantum Algorithm Zoo,
which categorizes known quantum algorithms and includes many references to original research papers that have contributed to their development.
For this series, however, we're just going to stick with the fundamentals, and starting with the next lesson, we'll move on to a new topic.
But first, let's talk about Grover's algorithm.
Here is the lesson overview.
We'll begin with a short discussion of the computational problem that we'll be addressing, which is unstructured search.
Intuitively speaking, you can think about the unstructured search problem as searching through a collection of items that isn't sorted and hasn't been ordered in a useful way.
Then we'll discuss Grover's algorithm, which is a quantum algorithm that offers a quadratic advantage over classical algorithms, and we'll get into precisely what that means shortly.
A very high-level description of how this algorithm works is that first there's an initialization step, and then an operation that I'll refer to as the Grover operation is iterated some number of times.
And then finally, a measurement takes place that reveals a candidate solution to the search problem.
I'll explain what the Grover operation is and how it can be implemented on a quantum computer, and then we'll go through an analysis of this operation to better understand what it does and why it's useful for searching.
The third part of the lesson is concerned with the number of iterations in Grover's algorithm, or in other words, the number of times the Grover operation should be applied,
presuming that we wish to maximize the likelihood that the algorithm succeeds in finding whatever it is that we're searching for while simultaneously minimizing its cost.
We'll start with the unique search problem, which is a special case in which there's exactly one solution to our search problem,
and then we'll consider what happens when there are multiple solutions.
And finally, I'll conclude the lesson with a few brief remarks about Grover's algorithm and its generalizations.
Let's begin with the computational problem that we'll be addressing throughout the lesson.
First, as we often do, we're going to let sigma denote the binary alphabet, and we'll use this notation for the entirety of the lesson, so I won't keep reminding you.
Suppose that we have a function f that maps binary strings of some length n to the binary alphabet.
Our assumption is that we can easily evaluate this function.
For example, maybe we have a Boolean circuit for this function whose size is polynomial in n.
Now, this doesn't mean that this is necessarily a simple function in any sense, or that we have a particularly good understanding of this function.
For instance, maybe we have a rather complicated and messy Boolean circuit for computing f that allows us to evaluate it on different input strings,
but doesn't necessarily have a nice form that's designed to make our lives easier.
Our goal is to find a solution by which we mean a binary string of length n that causes f to evaluate to 1.
In general, this is a very difficult computational problem, or at least we suspect that it's very difficult.
In particular, if the input is in fact the description of a Boolean circuit for computing the function f, then this is a so-called NP-complete problem.
One way that we can formalize this problem is as a query problem.
And indeed, for the purposes of this lesson, it's reasonable to think about this problem purely in the context of the query model.
But when we think about where or when this problem might arise in practice,
it's arguably more natural to think about f as being computed by a Boolean circuit.
As we saw in lesson 6, though, we can connect these two points of view through the construction that we went through
for taking a Boolean circuit and converting it into a quantum circuit for implementing a query operation or a query gate.
In any case, conceptually speaking, the input to the problem is this function f, and we're looking for a solution if there is one.
And if there isn't a solution, meaning that f turns out to be the constant zero function,
then the correct output is to report that there are no solutions.
This is an unstructured search problem in the sense that there's nothing special about f that makes it easy to find a solution.
It's not like we're searching through data that's already been ordered or that's been loaded into a data structure of some sort
that facilitates searching, and there's no promise on the function f that might help us.
One way to think about it is that it's like searching for a particular phone number in a phone book,
as opposed to searching for a name, which is much easier, presuming that the names have been alphabetized.
In practical terms, it's not really about searching through data, which we tend to organize and store in a manner that makes searching easy.
It's more representative of searching for a solution to a complicated equation, for instance,
or perhaps searching for the combination that opens a lock.
As an aside, it is sensible to think about this problem in the context of the query model,
regardless of how we might feel about the practical relevance of that model.
Of course, there aren't oracles or black boxes in real life, but until we learn otherwise,
complicated and mysterious Boolean circuits are kind of like black boxes.
Now let's think about algorithms for solving this unstructured search problem,
and we're going to be doing this in the query model just for the sake of simplicity.
If we have a Boolean circuit for our function rather than a black box, then we can still run query algorithms on it,
but of course we can't rule out the possibility that some new algorithm is discovered for this problem that isn't based on making queries,
but we won't concern ourselves with that possibility.
First, just a little bit of notation.
The total number of input strings to the function f is 2 to the little n, where little n is the length of the input strings to f,
and hereafter I'm going to let big N be this number, 2 to the little n.
It's pretty common that people use a capital letter like this to denote 2 to the power of the lowercase version of that letter.
We're going to be talking about the number capital N quite a lot, so this is just going to be convenient,
and it'll help to keep things a little bit neater.
And again, this notation holds for the entire lesson.
Now, of course we can solve the search problem classically by simply iterating through all of the possible n-bit strings
in whatever order we choose, evaluating f on each one of them.
If we find a solution at any point, we can stop, but in the worst case, we'll end up evaluating f on every single input string.
So, this requires n, meaning capital N, queries.
We could choose to measure the cost of this computation in a different way, not just in terms of the number of queries,
but the number of queries represents the number of times we have to evaluate the function f,
and it's reasonable to expect that the evaluations of f will dominate the cost of this computation.
This is, in fact, the best we can do with a deterministic algorithm, and again, this is in the context of the query model.
If we've queried every input string except for one of them, and f has taken the value 0 on all of them so far,
how can we be sure that the last string isn't a solution?
And the answer is that we can't, so we do need all n queries, in the worst case.
We could also use randomness. That can offer some very minor improvements,
such as reducing the expected number of queries needed to find a solution when one exists,
or we could effectively trade correctness probability for a reduction in queries,
but however you slice it, we'll still need a number of queries that's linear in n.
So, classically speaking, we need a linear number of queries, meaning linear in capital N.
Grover's algorithm is a quantum algorithm for search that does better.
It requires just big O of the square root of n queries.
Those queries happen in superposition, so it isn't magic,
but it is a significant improvement over what's possible classically,
and this is what's meant by a quadratic advantage.
Can this quadratic advantage of quantum over classical be turned into an actual advantage in a practical sense?
Probably not anytime soon, but in the distant future, who knows?
But even if Grover's algorithm doesn't ever lead to a practical advantage for searching,
it is nevertheless an important part of the foundation of quantum algorithms that's well worth understanding.
Before we move on to Grover's algorithm itself, we need to talk briefly about so-called phase query gates.
Many quantum algorithms in the query model are naturally expressed using phase query gates,
and we'll see that Grover's algorithm is a specific example.
Let's start with a quick review of ordinary query gates.
For a function f of the form that we've been talking about,
the query gate uf is defined on standard basis states, as is shown on the screen,
and for superpositions of standard basis states, the action is determined by linearity.
And it's worth reminding ourselves that from a Boolean circuit for f,
we can in fact build a circuit for this operation uf at a cost that's linear in the size of the Boolean circuit.
The phase query gate for f, on the other hand, which we'll denote by the name zf, operates like this.
In particular, this gate operates on little n qubits as opposed to little n plus 1 qubits,
and it basically just automatically kicks the function value into the phase,
rather than XORing the output value onto an additional qubit like we have for uf.
So if we think about what happens when we use phase kickback on a uf gate,
we're basically just implementing a zf gate.
We need a minus state, and it costs one evaluation of uf,
but we do in fact get the minus state back, and we can use it for the next one if we want to,
or we could just throw it away.
So that's what a phase query gate is.
Now, if we're just given a phase query gate zf, and this is the only way that we have access to the function f,
then we can't actually recover a uf gate.
But if we have a controlled version of zf, then we can build a uf gate,
and I'll leave that one to you as an exercise.
In addition to the phase query gate for the function f,
we're also going to need a phase query gate for the n-bit OR function,
or in other words the function that takes value 0 when it's given the L0 string,
and otherwise it takes the value 1.
And explicitly the way that XOR works on standard basis states is shown here on the screen.
This gate doesn't have any dependence on the function f, so it doesn't require any queries,
and one way that we can build a quantum circuit that implements this operation
is by doing something similar to what we did for the function f,
except that we start with a Boolean circuit that computes the OR function on n bits.
And now that we have these gates, we're ready to move on to the next section.
Now we'll discuss Grover's algorithm, beginning with a description of the algorithm.
We start by initializing little n qubits each to the plus state,
or in other words, we put these qubits into an equal superposition of all binary strings of length n.
What we're going to do is effectively to steer the state of these qubits toward a solution.
So it's intuitive that we start in this state because we don't know anything about the function f yet.
At this point, every string is equally likely to be a solution,
and that's reflected by the fact that these qubits are in an equal superposition of all strings.
And then we iterate. We repeatedly apply the Grover operation,
which is really the heart of the algorithm, and I'll describe it in just a moment.
We apply this operation a total of t times, where t is some non-negative integer,
but this number isn't actually specified by the algorithm itself.
We have to choose t somehow, and in the next section we're going to talk about good choices for t.
But for now, we can think about this number of iterations t as being arbitrary.
And finally, we measure in the standard basis, and that gives us a candidate solution.
There's no guarantee that it is a solution, but if we choose t well,
then the probability to get a solution can be made large.
And here is the Grover operation itself, which we've named g.
It's a composition of operations, all of them on n qubits, so this is an n-qubit operation.
First, we have a zf gate, or in other words, a phase query gate for the input function f,
followed by a layer of Hadamard gates, and then we have zor,
which is the phase query gate for the or function, and finally, another layer of Hadamard gates.
So, we see that one iteration in step two can be implemented by a circuit having the form shown here on the screen.
And here we have four qubits, by the way, but in general we can have any number of qubits.
A key thing to note here is that we need one query of f to implement g.
We need one query to implement zf, and none of the other operations have any dependence on f, so they don't require any queries.
So, this number t that represents the number of times we apply g in step two also represents the number of queries we need.
Here's a typical way that we might use Grover's algorithm, but it's certainly not the only way.
Like I said before, the first thing that we need to do is to choose t, and we'll get into that in the next section.
For whatever t we choose, we run Grover's algorithm for t iterations, and we get a candidate solution x.
There's no guarantee that x is really a solution, but we can spend one additional query to check.
If we have a solution, then we can output that solution and stop, and otherwise we can either try again,
possibly with a different choice of t, but not necessarily, or we can give up and report that there aren't any solutions.
Like I said before, this is not the only way the algorithm might be used, but this is a natural way of applying it to the search problem.
Next, we'll see what the Grover operation actually does to the state of the n qubits that it acts on.
Let's think of our n qubits as forming a single register, which I'll name q just to pick a name.
Remember that what we do first in Grover's algorithm is to put q into a uniform superposition of all n-bit strings,
and we do that by applying Hadamard gates to n qubits in the alt-zero state.
We then iterate the Grover operation G, and then measure.
It's going to be helpful to partition the set of all n-bit strings into two sets, A0 and A1.
A0 contains all the strings that cause f to evaluate to 0, and A1 contains all the strings that cause f to evaluate to 1.
Another way to say that is that A1 contains all the solutions to our search problem, while A0 contains all of the non-solutions.
We'll be especially interested in two quantum states.
One is the uniform superposition over all the non-solutions, that's ket A0, and the other is uniform over all the solutions, and that one is ket A1.
I should point out that these definitions only make sense when these sets are non-empty, because otherwise we're summing up 0 things and dividing by 0.
And as we go through this analysis of Grover's algorithm, we will be making that assumption.
We can very easily figure out what Grover's algorithm does when f is either the constant 0 function or the constant 1 function by treating them as special cases,
but I will leave that for you to do on your own.
Not surprisingly, if every string is a solution, we will indeed obtain a solution when we measure,
and if there aren't any solutions, then we won't obtain one, because in that case there aren't any.
But for the sake of this analysis, we're going to assume that both of these sets are non-empty, so that these definitions of these two states make sense.
By the way, this is a pretty common notation.
Whenever we have a non-empty finite set S, we can write ket S to mean the uniform superposition over the elements of that set, just like we have here.
So let's collect these definitions like this, and we'll see how they connect to Grover's algorithm.
The first step of Grover's algorithm is the initialization step, which puts Q into a uniform superposition over all n-bit strings.
And just to give this state an easily recognizable name, I'm going to call it ket U. U is short for uniform.
It's important for the sake of the analysis that we first note that this uniform state, ket U, is contained in the subspace spanned by the two vectors ket A0 and ket A1.
In particular, if we take the linear combination of these two states that's shown here on the screen, we'll get ket U.
Now, the key to the entire analysis is the fact that the state of Q remains in this two-dimensional subspace, no matter how many times we apply the Grover operation.
So everything is going to boil down to what happens in a two-dimensional subspace.
Now let's see what the Grover operation does, and in particular, what it does to vectors in the two-dimensional subspace spanned by ket A0 and ket A1.
It's helpful to imagine that G is split into two parts. One part is the ZF gate, and the other part is the ZOR gate, sandwiched between two layers of Hadamard gates.
Here's the definition of ZF from before, and it's pretty straightforward from that definition to see that its action on our two states, the uniform superpositions of non-solutions and solutions,
is simply to put a minus sign in front of ket A1 while nothing happens to ket A0.
And that's all we really need to know about ZF for the sake of this analysis.
For the second part, which is the ZOR gate sandwiched between two layers of Hadamard gates, let's start by recalling how ZOR is defined.
One way to write it is as is shown on the screen. This is the same expression as before, and another way to express it using the Dirac notation is like this.
And you can verify this expression just by thinking about how the operation on the right-hand side acts on standard basis states.
In particular, it does nothing to the all zero state, and every other standard basis state gets a minus sign, which agrees with the definition of ZOR.
So, if we sandwich this operation between two layers of Hadamard gates, then we get a similar expression, except that in place of the all zero standard basis state, we now have our uniform superposition ket U.
And that's because H tensor N transforms the all zero standard basis state to ket U, and also H tensor N is its own conjugate transpose, so it works in a similar way, acting from the right on the bra rather than the ket.
And now we're going to figure out what G does to our two vectors, A0 and A1, using the facts that we've just observed. Let's start with A0.
First, let's substitute the expression we obtained for the ZOR gate sandwiched between two layers of Hadamard gates.
Next, we can use the fact that ZF does nothing to ket A0, so we can get rid of the ZF operation.
And now, using the description of ket U that we have up here, along with the fact that ket A0 and ket A1 are orthogonal unit vectors, we can compute the product of this bra right here and this ket, and what we get is the square root of the number of non-solutions divided by N.
We can use this fact to evaluate what we get, and by substituting in our expression for ket U and simplifying, we get the final result that's shown here on the screen.
In particular, notice that this vector is contained in the two dimensional subspace spanned by ket A0 and ket A1, as I suggested before, and moreover, the coefficients happen to be real numbers.
As always, verify this at your own pace if you choose to do that. I tend to go through these sorts of things quickly in these videos, with the expectation that you'll pause the video to give it some thought if you choose to do that.
So let's clean this up so that we can save the final result for later.
And now we'll do something similar for the vector ket A1.
We can use the same expression of G as before.
And this time, the ZF gate injects a minus sign, which here is reflected by the fact that we've swapped the two terms in the operation in parentheses.
We then proceed in a very similar way, and the final result is similar, except that the two coefficients are swapped and we now have a minus sign in front of one of them,
which is just how the algebra works out.
And again, you can check this at your own pace.
Notice that, once again, we have a real linear combination of our two vectors, ket A0 and ket A1.
We'll clean this one up as well, and we'll put the end result together with the other one, and now we can see how G acts on the subspace spanned by our two vectors.
One way to do that is to express it in terms of the two by two matrix M that's shown here on the screen.
And just to be clear, what we're doing here is we're associating the first row in the first column with ket A0 and the second row and column with ket A1.
So far in the series, we've really just used matrices to describe the way that operations work on standard basis states.
But it is common to use matrices to describe the actions of linear maps on different sets of vectors, not just standard basis states.
And here we're talking about what the operation G does to the vectors ket A0 and ket A1.
We can say more about what G does to vectors in the span of ket A0 and ket A1 if we take a closer look at this matrix M.
And in particular, what we'll find is that M is a rotation matrix, meaning that its action on this two-dimensional space can be described as a rotation by some fixed angle.
There are a couple of different ways to see this, and one is to observe that this matrix M can be expressed as the square of a matrix that looks somewhat simpler.
That might be hard to spot if we're just looking at M by itself, but this isn't something that we need to discover on our own.
We just need to verify it, and we can do that by simply squaring the matrix on the right.
Another way to write the matrix on the right, not including the square, is shown on the screen.
And this is the typical way to describe a rotation by a given angle theta as a matrix.
The precise angle by which we're rotating happens to be the inverse sine of the square root of the number of solutions divided by N.
And by the way, because this is the first time that we're seeing it, let me point out that this angle is very important.
It's going to keep showing up as we continue with this analysis.
The argument of the inverse sine is a number between 0 and 1, and specifically the way that we're interpreting the inverse sine here is that it's the angle between 0 and pi over 2 that gives us the argument when we take the sine.
So that's one way to think about this matrix that we squared to get M.
And because squaring the matrix is the same thing as applying it twice, we see that M can alternatively be written as a rotation, not by an angle of theta, but by 2 times theta, because by squaring, we rotate by an angle of theta twice.
A different way to verify all this, by the way, in case it's helpful, is to start with this final expression of M and use the double angle formulas from trigonometry to obtain the original expression of M.
And this is the expression of M, which describes the action that G has on the subspace spanned by ket A0 and ket A1 that's going to be most useful going forward.
Now, returning to Grover's algorithm itself, after the initialization step, but before we perform any applications of G, the state of our n-qubit register Q is ket U, the uniform superposition over all n-bit strings.
And here we have the same expression of ket U in terms of ket A0 and ket A1 as before.
But now that we've identified this angle theta, we see that we could alternatively write ket U as cosine theta times ket A0 plus sine theta times ket A1.
That's clear for the coefficient of ket A1, and for the other coefficient, we just need to observe that the size of A0 plus the size of A1 is n, and then we can just get it from some basic trigonometry.
So that's the state we start with, and the first time that we apply G, we rotate by an angle of 2 times theta, so the total angle becomes 3 times theta.
And if we apply G again, the angle increases to 5 theta, because we've effectively rotated by an additional angle of 2 theta, and so on.
So after T applications of G, we can represent the state that we get, as is shown on the screen, where the angle of our state is equal to 2T plus 1 times theta.
That's 2 times theta for each application of G, along with an additional theta, because that's the state we started in.
We can also think about the action of the Grover operation in geometric terms, and this helps to shed some light on how it works, and why its effect is to rotate the state of the register Q.
Here's the main idea. The Grover operation is a composition of the two parts that we've already identified. One is ZF, and the other is ZOR, sandwiched between two layers of Hadamard gates.
These two parts are reflections, and when we compose two reflections, we obtain a rotation. So let's see how this works in more detail.
First, let's focus on ZF, and we're going to restrict our attention to the same two-dimensional subspace that we've been talking about, meaning the one that's spanned by ket A0 and ket A1.
As we already observed, the action of ZF on this space is quite simple. It does nothing to ket A0, and it puts a minus sign in front of ket A1.
This is a reflection, and specifically, it's a reflection about the line parallel to ket A0, which we'll call L1, just to give it a name.
To see why it's a reflection, it helps to draw a picture.
Here we have our two vectors, ket A0 and ket A1, which are orthogonal unit vectors, and we can think about the screen as consisting of all of the real linear combinations of these two vectors.
So the circle represents all of the unit vectors for which the coefficients of these two vectors are real numbers.
Here's the line L1, which is parallel to ket A0.
And if we consider some arbitrary vector psi on the circle, then the effect of applying ZF is to reflect about this line, as is illustrated on the screen, simply because we do nothing to ket A0, and we put a minus sign in front of ket A1.
In the special case that psi is ket A0, for instance, nothing happens when we perform this reflection.
And when psi is ket A1, the reflection takes us all the way to negative ket A1, and that's consistent with the action of ZF.
So ZF is a reflection that can be visualized as we have here.
The second part of G, which is ZOR sandwiched between two layers of Hadamard gates, can be expressed as 2 times ket U bra U minus the identity matrix, as we've already seen.
And again, this is a reflection, this time about the line L2 parallel to ket U rather than ket A0.
We can visualize this operation in a similar way to ZF.
Here's the vector ket U hypothetically.
So this is the line L2 parallel to ket U.
And once again, the action on an arbitrary vector psi is to reflect it about the line, which is L2 in this case.
And finally, as I mentioned before, whenever we compose two reflections, we obtain a rotation.
And specifically, it's a rotation by twice the angle between the lines of reflection.
So let's draw a similar picture to what we had before.
Here are the lines of reflection, which have the angle theta between them.
And if we take some arbitrary vector psi, reflect it around the first line L1, and then reflect it about the second line L2,
then the net effect will be to rotate the vector psi by an angle of twice theta.
And this is something that's true in general.
And you can try it out on some additional examples of your own to see that this is indeed the way it works.
Anyway, hopefully this helps you to get some intuition as to why the Grover operation has the effect of rotating vectors.
Next, we'll turn to the issue of choosing the number of iterations T in Grover's algorithm.
Let's start by thinking about how the analysis we've seen so far,
which reveals what the Grover operation does when we apply it repeatedly to the uniform superposition,
relates to the task that we're hoping to solve,
which is to find a solution to our search problem, or in other words, any string contained in the set A1.
In short, we're basically going to set a target,
and then figure out how many times to apply the Grover operation to get close to that target.
First, let's imagine that we have any state that's a linear combination of our two vectors ket A0 and ket A1.
If we perform a standard basis measurement on the state,
we're going to get an outcome in the set A1, which is the set A1.
we're going to get an outcome in the set A1, which is the set of solutions to our search problem,
with probability equal to the absolute value squared of whatever coefficient we have for ket A1,
and for the vector that's shown on the screen, that coefficient is beta.
This is intuitive.
If we were to measure the state ket A0, we'd get a random non-solution,
and if we measured ket A1, we'd get a random solution.
So, if we measure this state right here,
we'll get a random non-solution with probability absolute value of alpha squared,
and a random solution with probability absolute value of beta squared.
But we can also just take a moment to work it out.
Here's the state written out so that we can see what the entries of this vector are for standard basis states.
So, if we measure these are the probabilities to obtain each possible outcome,
and to get the probability to obtain a solution, we sum the probabilities for all the possible solutions,
which gives us the absolute value of beta squared as expected.
Now, we've already analyzed what happens when we run Grover's algorithm for t iterations.
We get the state that's shown here on the screen.
So, because the coefficient of ket A1 is the sine of 2t plus 1 times theta,
where once again here is this very important angle theta,
we will see a solution with probability sine squared of 2t plus 1 times theta.
We'd like to make that probability large, ideally as close to 1 as we can.
So, as we're rotating the state vector by iterating G,
we'll think about ket A1 as the target state,
and we'll try to pick t so that we land close to this state.
And as we're doing this, it's good to keep in mind that we'd also like to minimize t,
because that's the number of queries we need to make.
So, if we want to make this probability close to 1 and minimize t,
it makes sense to try to make the angle of our state vector close to pi over 2,
because that's the smallest angle that makes the square of the sine large,
so it's basically our first opportunity to make the probability large as we're rotating the state vector.
Now, we can't necessarily hit this angle pi over 2 exactly because t has to be an integer.
But if we think about it approximately and solve for t as if it were inequality,
then we see that ideally choosing t to be pi over 4 times theta minus 1 half makes sense.
But of course, t must be a non-negative integer.
So, what we'll do is to take the closest integer to what we're imagining is this ideal value,
which is the floor of pi divided by 4 times theta.
Taking the floor, by the way, just means that we throw away any fractional part.
So, in other words, it's the largest integer that's less than or equal to whatever it is that we're taking the floor of.
According to this expression, if the ideal value happens to be halfway between integers,
we'll round up, but that won't actually matter at all for the sake of this lesson.
So, going forward, we're going to be focusing on this particular choice of t.
But there is one other important consideration that we need to make,
which is that this specification of t depends on how many solutions there are,
because the angle theta depends on the number of solutions.
Hereafter, I'm going to use the letter S to refer to the number of solutions,
or in other words, the size of the set A1, just for the sake of convenience.
Anyway, the point is that our expression for t, the value that we're hypothesizing should be good,
depends on theta, and theta depends on S, which is the size of the set A1.
This isn't a problem if we know in advance how many solutions there are,
but if we don't know how many solutions there are in advance,
we don't know what theta is, so we can't pick t like this, and we'll have to do something different.
I'll come back to the situation where we don't know S a little bit later,
but to start, let's focus on the situation in which we do know how many solutions there are,
beginning with unique search, where there's guaranteed to be a single unique solution that we're looking for.
I mentioned the unique search problem as an example of a query problem back in Lesson 5.
The input is a function f from n-bits to 1-bit.
There's a unique n-bit string that causes f to evaluate to 1, and the goal is to output that string.
So, this is equivalent to the unstructured search problem we've been talking about,
but with the promise that there's exactly one solution.
And in fact, this is the only version of the search problem that Love Grover considered in his original 1996 paper
that introduced Grover's algorithm.
For unique search, we have that S equals 1,
and therefore this important angle theta is equal to the inverse sine of the square root of 1 over n.
When n is large, this value is approximately the square root of 1 over n,
and that's because for smaller and smaller angles,
the sine function starts to look more and more like the identity function.
If we substitute that approximation into our selection for t,
we see that t is approximately the floor of pi over 4 times the square root of n.
That's good, because we're on track to be using big O of the square root of n queries,
although at this point, we've yet to take a look at exactly how well the algorithm performs.
Let's take a look at an example where capital N is 128, which is 2 to the power 7.
So, our function f is from 7 bits to 1 bit, and we're assuming that there's a unique solution,
but to figure out how well the algorithm works, we really only need to concern ourselves with the angle theta,
which we can calculate.
It's approximately 0.0885 radians, which is a little bit more than 5 degrees.
And if we plug that value into our expression for t, we get 8.
So, we're thinking about what happens when we search for a unique solution out of 128 possibilities using 8 queries.
We can draw a picture to illustrate how the state changes over time as we perform iterations of the Grover operation.
As before, we had the states ket a0 and ket a1, and in this particular case, meaning unique search,
we have that ket a1 is in fact the standard basis state corresponding to the unique solution,
whatever it happens to be, while ket a0 is the uniform superposition over all strings besides the unique solution.
Here's the uniform superposition over all strings, which we can write as cosine theta ket a0 plus sine theta ket a1.
And it makes sense that ket a0 and ket u are close in this case because, as we just observed a moment ago,
ket a0 is almost the uniform superposition over all strings.
There's only one string missing, and that's the unique solution.
Applying g again rotates by an additional 2 theta, so this is where we are after two iterations.
Here's 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, and 8.
And now we see that we're pretty close to ket a1.
So, if we stop and measure at this point, we'll be quite likely to get the unique solution.
And in fact, in this case, there's only about a half a percent chance that we don't get the unique solution.
On the other hand, if we were to continue applying the Grover operation more than the recommended 8 times,
then the probability to get a solution would go back down,
and over time it would oscillate as the state goes around the circle.
So, it's important that we stop the iterations at the right time if we want to succeed with high probability.
Let's think about the probability that our choice for t reveals the unique solution more generally for different values of n.
We'll write p and 1 to denote the probability that Grover's algorithm succeeds in finding a unique solution for each possible value of n.
The 1 means one solution, and we'll extend this notation to other numbers of solutions shortly.
Here's a table of these probabilities for small powers of 2.
It starts with n equals 2, and the probability is one half, which isn't very good.
But then for n equals 4, the probability is exactly 1.
So, it actually works perfectly in this case.
It's a great exercise, by the way, to explicitly go through how these two cases work, particularly the case that n is equal to 4.
In that case, we're searching for one solution out of four possibilities.
We need just a single query, and it works perfectly.
As n gets larger, we do see some fluctuations.
The probabilities go up and down a little bit, but they appear to be getting closer to 1.
And indeed, that is true.
It can be proved analytically that the probability is always at least 1 minus 1 over n.
So, that's good.
The algorithm isn't perfect.
We're not guaranteed to get a solution, but it's quite likely, particularly for large values of n,
as well as the very interesting anomaly that happens when n is equal to 4.
I should also point out that we can always run the entire algorithm, including the measurements, as many times as we choose.
And if any one of the runs succeeds, we'll get a solution.
So, if these probabilities aren't good enough, we can easily boost them by just running the algorithm.
In fact, even if these probabilities were all equal to one half, for instance, we'd still have a useful searching algorithm.
Now, let's consider what happens when there are multiple solutions.
We'll start with a similar example to the one before.
Again, n is equal to 128, but this time, the number of solutions s is 4 rather than 1.
Again, we can calculate theta and t equal to 1.
Again, we can calculate theta and t, and we get that theta is about 0.1777, or a bit more than 10 degrees, and t is 4 this time.
So, the angle is about twice the value from the previous example, and t is half of what it was.
We can draw a picture like before.
Here's where we start.
Here's one iteration, two, three, and four.
This time, we're very close to cat A1, and the probability to get a solution this time turns out to be greater than 99.9%.
But if we didn't know any better, and we thought that there was only one solution, we would take t to be 8 like before.
We'd rotate almost all the way around to negative cat A0, and that would lead to a very small probability of success.
So, that's a further example showing that there are good choices of t and bad choices of t,
and here we see that a good choice for s equals 1 turns out to be a very bad choice for s equals 4.
But, assuming that we do know s in advance, and we choose t according to our specification,
then it turns out that Grover's algorithm will find a solution with probability at least 1 minus s over n, and often it'll be much larger than that.
It's also at least s over n, but that's actually much less interesting.
What's more interesting is that as the fraction s over n gets small, the bound on the probability of success gets closer and closer to 1.
Now, as I've already remarked several times, the number t represents not only the number of iterations of the Grover operation we've performed, but also the number of queries we're making.
So, how does this number depend on s and n?
First, let's start with the fact that the inverse sine of x is always at least x, provided that x is between 0 and 1.
That's pretty easy to show if you happen to know the Taylor series for the inverse sine function, but there are other ways to reason it, and we're just going to take this as given, because it's true.
That means that theta is at least the square root of s over n, and consequently, t is at most pi over 4 times the square root of n over s.
So, that's actually even better than big O of root n.
The larger s is in comparison to n, the fewer queries we need to make.
And in a way, it's not surprising that this fraction shows up like this, given that its reciprocal defines theta.
And at the end of the day, theta is really all that matters for this analysis.
As we've just seen, Grover's algorithm works quite well when we know in advance how many solutions there are.
But what if we don't know how many solutions there are?
There's one pretty simple approach, and that is to just choose the number of iterations randomly.
And specifically, choosing t uniformly at random, between 1 and the floor of pi over 4 times root n, turns out to be a pretty good way to do this.
The upper end of this range is roughly the number of queries we would choose for unique search.
And actually, it's exactly the right number in most cases.
This is when the angle theta is as small as it can possibly be, excluding the trivial case when there aren't any solutions.
The idea here is that instead of carefully aiming our state vector at ket A1, like we did when we knew how many solutions there were,
we're basically rotating by a random angle, as if we're just giving the state vector a random spin.
If there happens to be just one solution, then our random spin could push the state vector close to ket A1, but it might also just go part way there.
And if there happens to be many solutions, then our random spin could potentially send the state vector around the circle multiple times.
So we don't expect this to reveal a solution with a probability close to 1, but the chance that this leads to a solution, if there is one, turns out to be pretty good.
It's always at least 40%, in fact.
That's not obvious, but it is the case.
It certainly isn't shocking, though, because a truly random angle would have a 50% chance of finding a solution.
Anyway, 40% is not bad, and remember that we can always boost the probability of finding a solution by repeating the process, choosing t independently each time.
By doing this, the chances of not finding a solution when there is one decreases exponentially in the number of times we repeat.
So if we want a 99% chance to find a solution, what we can do is to run this simple approach 10 times, again with t chosen independently each time.
Naturally, if we don't find a solution, we output no solutions.
If there aren't any solutions, we won't find one, and so in that case, we'll always output the correct answer, which is no solutions.
If there are solutions, we might fail to find one and incorrectly declare that there are no solutions, but the probability of that happening can be made very small.
We also have, as I mentioned a few moments ago, that this requires a number of queries or evaluations of f that's big O of root n.
So, using Grover's algorithm, we can still solve the search problem with high probability with big O of root n queries, even if we don't know in advance how many solutions there are.
There's also a more sophisticated approach that can lead to a reduction in the number of queries as the number of solutions grows.
I won't describe it in detail though, and instead I'll just focus on the main idea.
We start with capital T being equal to 1. We then run Grover's algorithm for a random number of iterations, but where the upper bound is t.
So, the first time we get to step two, we're going to run Grover's algorithm with one iteration, but t is going to be growing.
If we find a solution, then we output that solution and we stop, and if we don't find a solution, we make t larger and try again.
And at some point, before t gets too large, we'll terminate the process and we'll declare that there aren't any solutions.
It's the same basic idea as we have in the simple approach, where we're giving the state vector random spins essentially,
but here we're starting out with lighter spins first, where t is small, just in case there are a lot of solutions.
In this way, we won't waste queries by making the state go around and around the circle by spinning too hard.
But if it doesn't work, meaning that we don't find a solution, we try again, but we spin a little bit harder, or potentially a little bit harder.
To make this work, the rate of increase of t has to be chosen carefully.
And one way to make it work is to replace t by the ceiling of five-fourths times t.
So t is being increased exponentially, and intuitively we can think about it as spinning 25% harder each time.
And it's important for the analysis that t increases exponentially like this.
Why five-fourths, you might ask? Well, it's just a number that works, and there's actually a range of values that work.
But two doesn't work, for instance. Doubling t each time is too fast of an increase to take full advantage of the benefits of lighter spins.
Anyway, the point of this more sophisticated method is that it gives the same asymptotic bound on the number of queries we require as we had before.
Big O of the square root of n over s. But we don't need to know in advance how many solutions there are.
And by the way, we can stop this process when t gets to root n. So if there aren't any solutions, we'll reach that conclusion after Big O of root n queries.
And that is how we can choose the number of iterations in Grover's algorithm.
To conclude the lesson, I'll make just a few brief remarks about Grover's algorithm.
First, within the query model, Grover's algorithm is asymptotically optimal.
What that means is that it's not possible to come up with a query algorithm for solving the search problem, or even the unique search problem specifically,
that uses asymptotically fewer than Big O of root n queries in the worst case.
That's something that can be proved rigorously, and there are in fact multiple known proofs of this fact.
Interestingly, this was known even before Grover's algorithm was discovered.
Grover's algorithm matched the already known lower bound on the number of queries required.
From time to time, people do come up with approaches that they believe are asymptotically superior to Grover's algorithm,
but there's always either a mistake or an assumption about the function f and how it can be accessed,
or some other problematic issue that renders the claim incorrect.
If you're working properly within the query model, you can't beat Grover's algorithm for unstructured search.
Second, Grover's algorithm is quite broadly applicable, in the sense that the square root speedup that Grover's algorithm offers for the unstructured search problem
can be obtained in a variety of different settings.
For example, sometimes it's possible to use Grover's algorithm on top of another algorithm to get a quadratic improvement beyond the performance of that algorithm.
Grover's algorithm is also quite commonly used as a subroutine inside of other quantum algorithms.
As just one simple example, we can use Grover's algorithm to get a quadratic advantage over classical algorithms for the minimum problem that I mentioned in Lesson 5.
And finally, the technique used in Grover's algorithm, where we have two reflections that are composed and iterated to rotate a quantum state vector,
can be generalized in a pretty major way.
An example is a technique known as amplitude amplification, where a process that generalizes Grover's algorithm
can be applied to another quantum algorithm to essentially boost its success probability quadratically faster than would be possible classically.
And that technique has broad applications in quantum algorithms.
So, it may be true that Grover's algorithm isn't likely to lead to a practical quantum advantage anytime soon, if ever,
but Grover's algorithm is, without a doubt, a fundamentally important and broadly applicable quantum algorithm.
And it's representative of a more general technique that has many uses.
And that's it for this lesson, and for this unit of the series, which has been on quantum algorithms.
We discussed the query model and how we can connect it to a more standard model of computation,
along with some other foundational concepts concerning how we can measure computational cost.
We then covered phase estimation and factoring, and then, finally, Grover's algorithm.
As I've already suggested, there is a lot more to learn about quantum algorithms,
but in this series, we'll move on to a different topic in the next unit.
In particular, we'll take a look at quantum algorithms,
and the next unit.
In particular, we'll take a look at the general formulation of quantum information,
where quantum states are represented by matrices of a certain sort known as density matrices.
As we'll see, this formulation turns out to be very useful,
and indeed essential for understanding some aspects of quantum information.
And it also happens to be quite beautiful from a mathematical viewpoint.
So, I hope you'll join me for unit three, and goodbye until then.
Thank you.